lose the glasses your glares ruining the
quality of the chant I'll be blind again
this could be a great reaction if you
play the consider hey what's up reject
nation I'm Greg Alba with the struggle
nation we are colliding forces together
when two reaction channels come together
you got to cover something Marvel
related right you got to ever see mighty
raccoons videos of course mighty raccoon
has the video put up a few days ago
what if Avengers endgame had a dark
ending I wonder where this is gonna go
Oh God oh is that for you it would be a
bummer it would be sad we're part two I
would be like we should set through all
the MCU ends Dovi that'd be freaking
hilarious but let's watch it I enjoy his
videos should be fun
[Music]
he changed the quality so he doesn't get
strong
it works
[Music]
whoa
[Laughter]
yeah
Oh No
Howie Jesus
[Music]
y'all would never want to see this
whatever why don't we just stand there
gonna look that happy do something what
are you doing no no that's not candid no
no no no that was directed by oh no no
no I D
No is he gonna play the whole credits
yeah P is that most of the video whoa
mighty raccoon super committed to
filling up some runtime with the actual
credits of the movie it's a great video
but you know no wow
oh dude decent good looking credits
though you man if that happened the
actual I'd have to leave the theater I'd
fight somebody at the theater oh yeah
and I'd leave I would be like [ __ ]
him getting like a brutal beatdown like
that sucks
fathomable sorry the one unfathomable
Iron Man's is looking at him yeah just
let that host like right up to him yeah
that's not going down like that that was
the part of it that I just couldn't
believe because that because he's
looking at that dr. strange is there
everyone else is there they would do
something but he saw them all someone
would do something to take care of that
I mean the concept of Thanos actually
was I wasn't expecting that sometimes
mighty racoon does that worry just goes
for like brutal beatdown moments you see
with my raccoon I mean I don't know like
is if it's a team or a person do you
know I don't know is a person but I
don't know I don't know for sure
sometimes he makes these what-if
scenarios we're like oh that isn't
interesting whatever oh that would be
cool yeah I feel like he was just having
a good laugh yeah exactly
yeah usually like when he did definite
he did Joe covers Pennywise yeah yeah
but see you know how now and that was
good like in reality that's what we're
not reality but if they were actually
matched up that's what would happen this
no it wouldn't go down like that no it
wouldn't
no only because Tony starts looking
directly
it's like he's watching him the whole
time no no no just watch him just mom
that's what I think he's just messing
with us because it was funny at first he
wanted this reaction he got it he wanted
you wanted this reaction so know me well
done mighty right come and get a man but
no no I wouldn't go down like that
can you imagine just actually sitting in
the theater I will be mad annoying
that's the ending you gave that's the
way you set me on fire but well done
because this is what you wanted you got
it you got the reaction you got it
definitely got the read it was effective
it was effective because I'm I'm be mad
for a week now frickin MC you screwed us
over do care about the fan did this this
is what journal talking about off-camera
the punching bag or something like I'm
mad now one of them should have stepped
in the whole time somebody somebody
watches yeah I love my you're accurate I
think it's a great I think this could
have been more powerful though if and
more fathomable if other characters
they're like exactly sorry shagging all
them um that's right the help and then
he couldn't but yeah that's train you
sir I do something holding your stare
like this looking like do something
oh no no no sure it's not real it's not
real
The Joker penny wise this one is not
really just just you mind your emotions
for a frog no would you have been
satisfied with this conclusion I love
how there's like 3.8 K dislikes screw
this still hit away subscribe and mighty
raccoon he's one of the best youtubers
out there
subscribe to hash tag struggle nation
he's a he's a good guy he's a nice guy
he's a funny guy that's rock he won't
smoke with me but he's a good guy you
can subscribe for the rejects click that
notification valve I wanted to mention
in a page front of the day shout out for
a man named JT he's smart he knows how
to get in contact with me because he see
I'm patron I reply to people in order of
which the messages come through so
sometimes I'm like a week late because
there's a lot of messages but JT has
found the wiggle room my Twitter account
Oh
prob winner I rarely check my Twitter so
he's first in line every time but I
rarely check my messages I'm like oh
it's been three weeks my bad I'm sorry
that's the quickest way to make sure
you're number one at something
appreciate it say hi to Japan know it
you're Japanese and your friend my wife
say hi to Hawaii for me for me too
mm-hmm you've been on why I would love
to go I can't afford it I'm a youtuber
hey I can afford it
what's the secret my secret as I can
[Laughter]